ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูต้อมสวัสดีสวัสดีค่ะผู้เอง
ตอนนี้ผีคนด้วยนะคะค่ะถ้าหากคุณต้องกับ
ครูเอ๋คืนนี้เป็นคลิปแรกเนาะคิดเฮาเลยนะ
คะเนี่ยก็ครูเอกขอแนะนำนะคะครูใหม่ 1 คู่
ใหม่ไหมให้ครู
นะคะซื้อขู่ต้อมนะคะเอ้ยให้เรียกคุณต้อง
หรือครูทอมมี่คะเรียกว่าครูต้อมก็ได้ค่ะ
ค่ะคุณต้อมนะคะกูต้องครูต้องกับครูเอ๋น่ะ
เพื่อนกันเป็นเพื่อนกันหน้าเป็นเพื่อนกัน
นะคะเดี๋ยวไว้อนาคตคู๋จะสัมภาษณ์อุดต้อม
เนาะก็นั่งนั่งอันคุยนั่งอยู่นะแล้วก็คิด
ค่ะก็วันนี้คือจะมีทำคลิปกับน้องอีกคนนึง
แล้วก็เอกกับพี่หนูสอนอะไรกับต้องดีนะคิด
แล้วก็เอกก็คิดได้ 1 อย่างเพราะว่าอันนี้
คะรุ่นเรารุ่นก็คืออายุคู่เอกก็กูถามอายุ
เท่ากันกันเข้าไหมอ่ะคุณต้อมน้อยกว่า
อย่างนิดนึงอ้ะกฎต่อมน้อยกว่ารุ่นเดียว
กันเรียนเวลาเด็กๆเนาะเวลาครูเอเน็ตกู
ต้อมเด็ก 2 คนเรียนด้วยกัน
หน้าค่ะกูต้องกับครูเอ๋เอ๋เรียนด้วยกัน
ตอนอายุเท่าไหร่คะครูต้อมโอ้โหนานมากแล้ว
ค่ะเรียนด้วยกันตอนอายุ
ต้อง 12 ไหม
10  11  12 ประมาณนี้ค่ะ 11 แล้วตอนนะ
น้อกูเอ๋ 13 อา
กูเอ 13 ตอนนั้นอายุ 13 ปีแต่ครูต้อง 11
เธอไปหาซื้อ
เรียนครูต้องกับครูเอ๋เรียนด้วยกันตอน
เด็กๆนะคะ 3 ปีนะคะ 3 ปีรหัสปี
ใช่ไหมแยกกันแยกกันไปเรียนที่อื่นค่ะเรา
ก็มาเจอเจ้านะคะต้องไปเรียนที่ 1 คู่เอก
ก็ไปเรียนที่ 1 แล้วนานไปก็กลับมาเจอกัน
โอ้ว
ไม่ต้องคิดกี่ปีนานมากตาลว่าแต่ว่าที่ถาม
ปันนี้เพราะว่าคนที่อยู่ในเวลาเดียวกัน
รักคือครูต้อมกับกูเองอ่ะจะมามีคนพ่อคุณ
แม่แล้วก็คุณแม่เนี่ยท้องแล้วก็คอมอ่ะพี่
เก๋ก็เวลาใกล้ๆกันเนาะคุณไรค่ะใกล้ๆกันก็
คือในเมื่อก่อนนะเนาะ God ทำให้กูเองคิด
เองวันนี้น่ะครูเอ๋คุยกับครูต้อมเรื่อง
เมื่อก่อนดีกว่า
ดีค่ะคุณต้อมก็ชอบคุยเรื่องเมื่อก่อนคิด
ถึงเรื่องเมื่อก่อนแล้วมันมีความสุขมาก
เฮ้ยแล้วเธอก็รู้สึกบางทีเราก็กลัวราะหัน
ๆๆหน้าเขาอย่างนี้ค่ะต้องสมัยต้อมค่ะนัก
เรียนค่ะต้องบอกนักเรียนด้วยนะคะสมัยที่
กรุต้อมกับครูเอ๋เป็นเด็กๆเอาเด็กเลยนะ
อายุ 5 ปี 5 ขวบมากครัว 5 ขวบ 6 ขวบ 7
ขวบเนาะอาจจะให้ภาพครูเอกขอเขียนดีกว่าทำ
ให้เขียนแล้วพูด
สมัยที่เราเราเป็นอยากเห็นเนาะ
มีคุณพ่อ
คุณคุณแม่คุณแม่คนไทยแบ่งทีกับพูดพูด
เรียบร้อยก็คุณพ่อคุณแม่หรือบางทีก็พ่อ
พ่อแม่
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยเป็นไทยจีนหืมพ่อเนี่ยไทย
แม่น่ะไทย
จีนน้อ
แม่เป็นครึ่งไทยเรื่องจีน Green  Blue
เอกก็จริงๆไทยมากกว่าจีนด้านล่างหน้าใน
จริงผู้ a
หน้าครูเอไม่เหมือนจีนแล้วนะคะหน้าครูเอ๋
เหมือนญี่ปุ่นเหมือนสาวญี่ปุ่นขอบคุณค่ะ
เออที่นี้เนี่ยคู๋นักเรียนมีนิดนึงอยากจะ
บอกเวลาปลุกมีเลขหน้ากูเองจะชอบดูกูต้อม
แล้วกูอีกอ่ะอิจฉาช้ำ
ไหมล่ะกูเหนชอบคนผิวสีสีน้ำตาล
ผู้ต้องสีแข้มซ้ายโอเคชอบสีน้ำตาลแล้วครู
เอกก็เพราะว่าคนผิวสีน้ำตาลจะตาโต
นี่ไงน้องว่าตาโตมากอ่าแล้วก็จมูกโด่งใช่
ป่ะไม่ชอบ
[เพลง]
จังนะฮะ
พระจันทร์แต่ว่าครูต้อมแนทดูแล้วไทยเนาะ
ไทยไทยว่าคุณเจ้าไทยคุณพ่อคุณแม่มีจีนไหม
คะไม่มีเลยค่ะคุณพ่อก็เป็นไทยคุณแม่ก็
เป็นไทยขอกูต้องได้ 200 เปอร์เซ็นต์เลยนะ
คะไทยเนี่ย
ก็ต้องเป็นคนไทย
200% สแก้ไขพื้นใช่คนไทยจะพูดเรียบร้อย
เรียบร้อยแล้วก็จะพูดช้ามากๆ
ป้าเรียบร้อยตัวเองอภัยจีนพ่อเนี่ยจะพูด
เหมือนๆกูต้องพูดช้าๆแม่พูดเร็ว
รู้เหรอ 55  10
พูดช้าโอเคพูดเร็วโอเค
เอา 2 อย่างเลยรวมกันทรายราคาก็แต่ว่าที่
ที่เห็นพูดว่าพ่อไทยอ่ะพ่อเป็นคนไทยเอกก็
ควรจะพูดคุณพ่อหรือว่าพ่อใช่ไหมคะแม่เป็น
จีนเอกก็ควรจะพูดเอาม้า
แต่ที่บ้านครูเอ๋น่ะคุณพ่อเนี่ยให้เรียก
ว่าเตี่ย
ขอเลือกเปรียบอาหารจีนภาษาจีนคุณพ่อเนี่ย
ชอบอยากเป็นคนจีนเพราะคุณพ่อ
รักปุ้ยสีแดงหรือเปล่า
Raspberry รักสาวจีนจะแวะอยากจะเป็นผู้
ชายจีนก็โหให้ลูกโรแมนติกนะพ่อเราเนี่ย
ให้ลูกเรียบพ่อ
วัดเตี่ยว่าเตี่ยเสี่ยงกับพ่อเหมือนกัน
ใช่ส่วนคุณแม่ก็อยากเป็นคนไทยอ้าวทำไม
แม่ออกแล้วเรียกแม่
ไม่คุยกับมาม๊าๆกูเอกก็เลยงงที่บ้านครู
เอ๋เนี่ยเลี้ยงพ่อที่เป็นคนไทยว่าเตี่ยก็
เมาเตี่ยเรียกแม่ที่เป็นคนจีนว่าแม่
เอกก็ไม่ได้คิดอะไรนะนักเรียนไม่มีอะไร
เพราะว่าถ้าภาษาไทยก็ติดพ่อแล้วก็แม่ราคา
กดต้อมแต่ว่าถ้าเป็นคนดีก็เอาป๊าเอาม้า
ม้าม้าม้าอ่าๆแต่บ้านคู๋เตี่ยกับแม่คู่
เองใกล้ๆบ้านกูเอกก็เหมือนกันถ้าบ้านไหน
เป็นพ่อไทยหรือพ่อจะพาพ่อจีนแม่ไผ่เขาก็
เรียกเมียกับแม่น้องพ่อมากรุงเทพฯอ่ะฟัง
เพื่อนที่กรุงเทพฯพูด
นิ่มแรก
ที่บ้านแปลกใช่ไหมคะๆมีคนบอก
ทำไมถึง
ทำไมอ่ะก็เลยต้องไปกลับบ้านพ่อทำไมต้อง
เรียกเตี่ยทำไมไม่เรียกพ่อพ่อบอกไม่เอา
ต้องเรียกเตี่ยแล้วพอกันเราต้องมา
พ่อก็รักแม่
ใช่พ่อก็เลยต้องเป็นอะไรนะคิดเหมือนคนจีน
นิดหน่อย
ที่เราคุยกันเรื่องพ่อแม่เนี่ยซ่อมเพราะ
ว่าเมื่อก่อนนะเวลาเราเด็กๆอ่ะใช่ไหมคำ
ว่าเราเด็กๆก็คืออายุเอ่อถ้าจำได้หรอก
เริ่มจำได้นิดหน่อยก็คืออายุตั้งแต่ 5
ขวบได้ไหมคะ 3  3 ขวบจำได้มั้ยจะไม่ได้ 3
ขวบจำได้นิดๆเออก็โอเคยังจำได้นิดหน่อยนะ
ถึง 13 นก 12
52 ขวบราคา
3 ขวบถึง 12 ขวบเนี่ยโอเคจำได้ท่านน้อย
กว่า 3 ขวบจำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้นะคะคุณต้อมคะ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋บ้านคูเอกก่อนนะคุณเอ๋อยาก
จะถามครูต้อมเวลากดต้อมเด็กๆอ่ะไอ้ 3 ขวบ
ยังไม่เท่าไหร่หรอกประมาณเต็มขวดเนี่ย 7
ขวบ
7 ขวบและเราต้องไปโรงเรียนเนาะใช่ค่ะอัน
นี้จากบ้านนะคะบ้าน
เราก็จะไป
โรงเรียนโรงเรียนประเทศไทย 6 มีธงชาตินี้
คงชาติไทย
ธงชาติก็อันนี้สีแดงเนาะ
สีแดง
ขาวแล้วก็ตรงกลางๆน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินไม่ไหม
แต่คุยหาสีน้ำเงินก่อน
โอเคไหมหานิทานของชาติอ่ะคะเป็นโรงเรียน
เวลาที่เราไปโรงเรียนเราเรียนหนังสือแล้ว
ใช่ไหมเราอาบได้แล้วเหนือหน้าเราเริ่ม
อ่านละคู๋นะจำได้เพราะคุยเริ่มอ่าน
หนังสือนะหรือว่าบางทีดูทีวีก็น่าจะเท้า
เด็กๆตอนเด็กไม่ได้ดูทีวีไม่ค่อยได้ดู
ทีวีอ่านหนังสือแล้วอยากจะนอนไหม
ง่วงอย่างนอนอยากนอนแต่กูเองอ่ะเวลาอ่าน
หนังสือไม่ใช่เรื่องสือเรียนนะคะนักเรียน
อยู่อะไรคะการ์ตูน
Batman  Superman
โดราเอหนังสือ
การ์ตูนนะคะหนังสือการ์ตูนคือหนังสือที่
เป็นแบบนั้นที่นี่แล้วก็มี
นี่คู๋ครูต้องมีเห้อกูต้องมีเหรอกูเองไม่
มีทางลูกชายคุณต้องการ์ตูนเยอะแยะเลยอ่าน
หนังสือการ์ตูนขอบคุณค่ะคุณพ่อ
เวลาอ่านหนังสือการ์ตูนเราอยากจะไปนอนไหม
คะอยากนอนค่ะอยากนอนอ่านจะสบายๆ
ก็อยากนอนแต่คู๋นะไม่ยอมนอนเฮ้ยทำไมล่ะคะ
หนังสือน่ะครูเอ๋จะไม่นอนตัวเองแล้วคะ
อ่านหนังสืออ่านๆไม่ไปนอน
แม้แต่พี่กับน้องพี่ชายกับน้องชายน่ะเล่น
เล่นโอ้โหก็ไม่ยอมไปนอนนะคะพาเด็กๆนอน
อ่านไม่ได้ต้องนั่งนั่งแล้วก็อ่านอ่าน
อ่าน
พ่อก็บอกไอ้พ่อไม่ว่าแม่แม่ๆแม่บอกไปนอน
ไปนอนไม่นอนกูเอคะแม่ให้กูเอ๋ไปนอนตอนกี่
โมงคะอุ้ย
20:00 น
ก็ไม่เอาไม่ใช่แม่ให้นอนประมาณ 19:00 น
แล้วมากอยู่ต่างจังหวัดครูต้อมของอายุ 7
ปีที่ ๗ ปี ๗  ๖  ๗ ขวบต้องนอนเร็วๆๆ 7
ขวบแล้วนะเร็วๆตอนนี้ไม่นอนโอเคตอนนี้
โอเค
7 ขวบแล้วคุณแม่บอกไปนอนแม่บอกไปนอนไม่
นอนยังพ่อบอกโอเคไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรอีก
นิดนึง
พอจะให้ถึงได้ถึง 20:00 น
แต่ไม่ทำใครดีมากกว่าใจดีเข้าใจดีแต่แม่
นะแม่ก็จะบอกแม่ก็จะเดินมา
[เพลง]
ไม่ดุใช่แม่บอกว่าทุกคนไปนอนมีหมายด้วยนะ
ที่มาแม่บอกว่าไปนอน
ถ้าไม่รีบนอนคุยอยู่คนเดียวด้วยนะเนี่ย
ถ้าไม่รีบนอนเดี๋ยวผี
[เพลง]
อ่า
หลวง
น้องพี่พอแล้วเอาขี่น่ารักนะ
คุณแม่บอกว่าน้อยน่ารักแม่บอกว่าถ้าไม่ไป
นอนนะถ้าไม่ยอมไปนอนน่ะเดี๋ยวผีจะมาจับคอ
หัวในแล้วก็ค่ะคอ
เฮ้ย
กลัวมากถ้าเจอแบบนี้ไปนอนนะคะคุณต้องนอน
ข้านอนน้องๆผีขอหักขอให้ครูต้อมกูต้องเคย
โดนคุณแม่หลอกแบบนี้ไหมคะกูต้องก็เคยคุณ
โดนคุณแม่หลอกเมื่อก่อนนี้ค่ะแต่ไม่ได้
บอกว่าผีมาหาคอนะคะแล้วบอกว่าผีอะมาบีขอ
มิ้มมี
ให้
พ่อปี 4GB หางานทำที่นอนให้ค่ะแถวก็เอา
ผ้าห่มมาคุณโอ๋ถ้าเขาจะเอาผ้าห่มค่ะคุณ
โปร่งเลยค่ะเป็นยังไงก็คุณโป่งโอ้ไม่เห็น
อันนี้อันนี้นี่ผีไม่มาหาเราใช่ไหมมีไม่
มากกลัวผีมากคุณเออทำไมขององค์แล้วผีไว้
มาใช่มั้ยแม่มันจะบอกว่าต้องคลุมโปงผีจะ
ไม่มาเจอผีมันมองไม่เห็นเราค่ะ A ผีหมอผี
ไม่เห็นเราไม่เห็นเรานี่ก็มีเอา B เรา
มองไม่เห็นผี
ทั้ง a และ b
2 อย่าง
น้าขอคุณแม่บอกแล้วคุณแม่คุณต้องบอกว่า
อะไรนะจะบีบคอๆดีจะมาบีบคอผม
ปูมาไว้ค่ะอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ว่ามันเป็น s กี่โมงแล้วกูต้อง
พูด
แม่หลอกกูเอกก็กลัวนะคุณต้องกลัวเวลาครู
เอกโตขึ้นมาคุยบอกพี่พี่พี่พี่มีลูก
ห้ามหลอกลูกแบบนี้นะโกรธนะไม่ได้ห้ามหลอก
นะคะแต่แต่ว่าจริงๆคุณพ่อคุณแม่อยากให้
เรานอนเร็วๆเราจะได้เป็นเด็กที่แข็งแรงไง
คะๆเพราะว่าเด็กๆถ้านอนมากๆโกสฮอร์โมนจะ
ทำงานดีแต่ว่าเด็กก็ไม่นอนไม่เอาไม่เอา
แต่พอบอกว่าผีจะมาเป็นยังไงคะนอน
นอนนะนอนเลยแต่ที่ได้มาคือ
พรุ่งนี้ว่ากลัวผีนะคะเราเป็นคนกลัวผีไป
เลยเห็นไหมแต่ถ้าเป็นตอนกลางเนื่องจาก
ต้องอันนี้ตอนกลางคืนใช่มั้งตอนกลางวัน
ถ้า
นักเรียนลบก่อนลบๆอันนี้ไปนอนพ่อแม่จะ
หลอกเราว่าผีจะมามีพอนะคะแต่ถ้าเป็นกลาง
วัน
เป็นกลางวันถ้ามีนอนกลางวันด้วยนะอ๋อใช่
ถ้าเด็กที่ตัวเล็กๆเล็กมากๆได้จบต้องนอน
ตอนกลางวันอย่างเช่นเด็กอนุบาลค่ะ Google
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ครูเอ๋อยู่บ้านใช่ไหม
ตอนเด็กๆที่บ้านมีให้นอนกลางวันเนี้ย
ดีมากค่ะคุณต้องมีไหมไม่มีให้เล่นไปเลย
ได้นอนกลางวันแล้วถ้ากลางวันมีพระอาทิตย์
ใช่ไหมอ่ะมีพระอาทิตย์
อ้ะมันทีเราก็ไม่อยากนอนเราก็เล่นเนี่ยก็
นอนแน่ๆแต่เวลาคุยเด็กๆคุณต้อมกูอีกไม่
แข็งแรง
แข็งแรงนะคะเนี่ยไม่สบายบ่อยๆพร้อมกับแม่
ก็เลยให้ไปนอนก็ไม่นอนจะไปเล่นเพราะจะไป
เล่นแป๊บพ่อกับแม่ก็จะบอกขอโทษนะคะนัก
เรียนพ่อกับแม่บอกอย่างนี้ค่ะกูต้อง S
นอนไม่นอน
เหอะพ่อกับแม่บอกว่าถ้าไม่นอนเดี๋ยวฝรั่ง
มา
อุ้ย
อ๋อ
มีคนไทยคนไทยตัวเตี้ยๆ
เด็กก็ตัวแค่นี้
ฝรั่งตัวใหญ่ๆ
พ่อกับแม่บอกว่าอ่ะจริงๆมาก่อนบอกยักษ์
ก่อนยักษ์ขอ
ยักษ์มีเขี้ยว
ขอ
ยักษ์จะสูงเราก็ใหญ่ค่ะอยากเป็นแบบนี้
เด็กๆทุกคนกลัวยักษ์นะกูเอกใช่
พ่อกับแม่จะบอกว่าเดี๋ยวยะ
ยัตจะมาจับกินยิน
แล้วก็วันนึงกูเอ๋น่ะวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งแล้วก็
ชนฝรั่ง
เอ้ามีมีฝรั่งไปทำงานแถวบ้านกูเอ๋ใครไป
ประมาณ 3 กิโลเมตรวิมไม่ได้แล้วก็วิ่งทน
ฝรั่งฝรั่ง
สูง
เป็นยังไงคะ
คลิปยัง
กูเอร้องไห้ไหมคะร้องไห้
ขอโทษนะคะฝรั่งเออคนยุโรป
ขอเบอร์คุยจำได้ผิวขาวๆผมสีบลอนด์ยักษ์
ระบบ Pro  No  I'm  not ยักษ์
ไม่เข้าใจคุยคิดยักษ์อ่า
วิ่งกลับบ้านร้องไห้
กลัวๆคุณแม่ก็
ดูแล้วเก๋ๆยักษ์เอ๋ทำให้นอนหลังวันจับ
จับ
จับกินไหมไอ้จับแล้วก็กินกินอ่ะกูเอกก็
เลยกลัว
[เพลง]
ข้างก่อนนะคะอันนี้คนไทยอ่ะคุณพ่อคุณแม่
จะให้ลูกไปนอนแต่ลูกไม่นอนก็เลยจะพูดอะไร
ที่น่ากลัวเราให้ไปนอนเราบอกว่าอย่าหลอก
เด็กใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะแล้วคุณต้องอะมีลูกไหม
มีค่ะกูต้องมีลูกชาย 1 คนกูต้องมีรูป
เดี๋ยวกูไอ้ว่านให้ไหมคะ
ครูต้อมครูต้อมแต่งงานแล้ว
ไม่ชนิดขูดต้อม
ต้อมแต่งงานแล้วกับผู้ชายผู้ชายสิคะแล้ว
ก็มีลูกชาย
มีลูกชาย 1 คนมีลูกชาย 1 คนคุณต้อมคะแล้ว
เวลาที่กูต้อง
เลี้ยงลูกเนี่ยมีเรื่องต้องหลอกเด็กหลอก
วะหลอกเด็กหลอกเด็กใช่มั้ยเอ่อลองตาหลอก
เด็กให้ไปนอนไหมคะ
มีค่ะนี่เดี๋ยวรอเดี๋ยวรุ่นคุณต้องยังมี
นะคะยังมีอยู่ค่าครูมีผู้เอกก็รุ่นเดียว
กันเราก็จำที่พ่อกับแม่บอกเราเมื่อก่อน
นี้ถ้าเอาก็จำเอามาพูดกับลูกเราค่ะแล้ว
คุณต้องไม่กลัวลูกจะกลัวเหรอคะไม่กลัวค่ะ
ก็อยากให้เขานอนแล้วก็แข็งแรงในคะอ๋อโอเค
โอเค
ครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนกูเอกกลัวผู้เอกก็
เลยนอนนะกูจะเบาะนอนเร็วๆถ้าไม่นอนจะ
หนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าพูด
ๆๆๆ
จะพูดกับหลานเราก็พูด
ยาว
จุดนอนแล้ว
นอนก็ได้
คู่มือ
กูเอไม่บอกว่าจะมีผีมียักษ์ไม่พูดพูดนั้น
นอนถ้าไม่นอนตัวก็ไม่สูง IQ จะไม่ดีโกส
ฮอร์โมนกันอยู่นี่นั่นอยู่ไหนใช่หลานครู
เอ๋ชื่อหญิงอายุ 3 ขวบฟังคู๋พูดๆหลานก็
ไม่เข้าใจนอน
และความปางขอโทษค่ะคุณต้อมหลอกลูกยังไงคะ
ลูกครูต้อมน่ะนอนนะคะเป็นเด็กดีนอนเร็ว
นอนเร็วก็ไม่ต้องช่องคะไม่ต้องหล่อแต่เขา
ไม่ชอบ
ห่มผ้าขะม้า
[เพลง]
เขาจะชอบดิ้น
แล้วผ้าก็หลุดๆๆ
เขาก็เลยพูดกับเขาหลอกเด็กว่าต้องห่มผ้า
ที่เท้าด้วยนะขอคุยมีเตียงนอนไห้ท่า
เตียงนอนอันนี้หมอนใช่ค่ะแล้วก็รู้กูต้อม
นะผ้าอยู่ไหนคะ
อยู่ผ้าห่มจะอยู่ที่ปลายเท้าค่ะอออยู่ที่
นี่ๆไม่คม
5 ให้เขาข่มแต่เขาไม่ห่มเห้ยเป็นสีฟ้า
เนาะกูต้องบอกว่าอะไรคะครูต้อมบอกว่าถ้า
ไม่ห่มผ้าเดี๋ยวค้างคาวสมัครจุ๊บพี่นิ้ว
เท้านะจุ๊บๆแบบนี้อะไรข้างๆ
ข่าวโอเคจุพร้าว
มีครั้งข่าวมีทั้งข่าวอ่ะ
กูจะเอาข้างเข้าไปให้
[เพลง]
เล่นตรงนี้เลยนะคะอ่ะโอเคอยู่ตรงนี้เลย
ค่ะกินข้าวมาไหมมาแล้วเนี่ยมันแล้วกลัว
มากๆเอาไหมใน
อ้าวถามจะมา
ข้าวจะมาจุ๊บที่เท้าเพราะคุณต้องพูดกับ
ลูกว่าค้างคาวค่ะมันจะชอบจุ๊บนิ้วเด็กที่
มันเย็นๆถ้าเกิดว่าเท้าเย็น on  5 เบรค
เท้าเย็นทั้งข้าวจะชอบมาก
มันจุ๊บจุ๊บ
ๆก็ไม่น่ากลัวสิหรือลูกกลัวข้างๆลูกกลัว
ค่ะจุ๊บแล้วมันอาจจะกลับด้วยมันเหมือน
เด็กชูล่าใช่มั้ย
อ๋อๆจัดหาหมอไงกับขี้อันนี้นะคะนักเรียน
อ่ะกูอยู่วัดเท้าให้
ที่เท้า
ขาวนี้ซึ่งไหมค่ะได้ค่ะ
พี่บอกคลังข่าวจะมากับเท้าได้ๆค่ะเลอะลูก
กูต้องทำยังไงคะห่มผ้าที่เท้าเลยค่ะจะไม่
มีเท้าโถ่ออกมาเลยค่ะ
[เพลง]
ได้หรอโอเคเราก็มีผ้าห่ม
นี่เลยน่ะคะป้ายค่ะข่มมิดเลยค่ะอ๋อ
ผม
ทำไมอ่ะกูต้องลูกไม่ห่มข้าเป็นอะไรลูกชอบ
ดิ้น
ลูกบอกว่านอน
ร้อนๆ
แต่ถ้าเขาถ้าคนนอนแล้วไม่มีผ้าห่มจะเขา
ไม่สบายหรือเปล่าคะ
ในห้องล่ะค่ะอันนี้ห้องนอนเราจะเปิดแอร์
อะไรจะเปิดแอร์ไว้อากาศเย็นค่ะเขาอ่ะจะ
ชอบเล่น
ขอเล่นก่อนนอนแล้วเขาก็จะนอน
แต่พอเขานอนไปแป๊บเดียวแป๊บเดียวก็จะเย็น
เย็นอาเดี๋ยวเขาก็จะไม่สบายคุณต้องก็เลย
ต้องให้เขาห่มผ้าเอาไว้เพราะว่าอากาศๆ
เย็นค่ะอ๋อถ้าเย็นนะเดี๋ยวไม่สบายๆลูกไม่
ยอมผมผ้าไม่ยอมห่มร้อนๆร้อนๆเดี๋ยวตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ลูกรู้หรือยังว่าครั้งคราวไม่มาจบ
ตอนนี้ลูกกูต้มตัวโตมากแล้วค่ะอายุ
16 แล้วค่ะ 16 ปีแล้วลูกลูกขุดต้อมผมผ้า
ไหมคะตอนนี้อุ้มฆ่าห่มผ้านะยังผมถ้ายัง
กลัวค้างคาวค้างๆน่ากลัวอยู่แล้วคะไม่
กลัวแล้วค่ะ
นักเรียนคะอ่อนน่ารักนะคะน่ารักตอบ
ก็เป็นเทคนิคให้ให้ลูกชิ้นกับการห่มผ้า
แสดงคะใช่ค่ะมีอย่างอื่นอีกนะคะนักเรียน
อย่างเช่นอ้ะมีเรื่องนึงอันนี้ไม่ใช่คุณ
อ้อมแล้วไอ้กูเอาคราวออกไปนะคะ
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้ลบมีเพื่อนครูเอ๋คนนึงทำงานด้วยกัน
นะคะถ้าทำงานด้วยกันแต่งงานแล้วก็มีลูก
สาว
ลูกสาวน่ารักเจ้าค่ะลูกสาวนะคะคุณพ่อเป็น
คนอังกฤษนะคะ
ลูกสาวอาคู่เห็นตั้งแต่
เล็กๆอายุ 3
32 ปีมีอายุ 2 ขวบ 2 ขวบ
อายุ 2 ขวบใช่มั้ยยังพูดไม่ได้
บางทีการเล่นเอ่อเล่นกันนะคะแล้วเด็กอะ
เด็กนะคะนักเรียนเขาจะไม่ได้ฟังที่เราบอก
แต่เขาจะดูเราเนี่ยทำอะไร
เราเนี่ยทำอะไรคู๋ชอบกินเขาก็ดูแล้วก็ตอน
นี้เขาก็ชอบกิน
เหมือน
คือไม่ใช่กูเอกก็เดี๋ยวพี่กูเองนะก็มีครู
ครูครูเบรคก็กินเขาก็ดูแต่คุณแม่น่ะไม่
ชอบกินคุณแม่กินนิดหน่อยอ๋อคุณแม่ตัวเล็ก
ๆ
คู๋ทำไมอ่ะโอเคตัวใหญ่ๆกินอะไรบ้างคะที่
เขามองเห็นก็มีกินอะไรนะกินเค้กกินผลไม้
มีข้าวกินกินป่ะกินทุกอย่างกินไหมโอเคกิน
ด้วยกันกินด้วยกัน
คุณแม่ไปทำงานกูเอกก็ดูให้อากินหรือวัน
ที่กูแอบไปทำงานเพื่อนเพื่อนอื่นกันดู
ด้วยกันก็
ทุกคนทำงานเบรคไม่ตรงกันนะเราก็กินแล้ว
ไม่อิ่มยินหรือยังออกคิดว่ายังไม่กินล่ะ
กินมั้ยอ๋อ
และเขากินทุกอย่างเลยเหรอคะ
ไม่ทุกอย่างอะไรที่ชอบรถกินนะคะ
แปะคูล a ชอบอันนึงคือไม่ท้องก็วันนี้ไม่
ใช่ผู้ตอบมาเพื่อนอ่ะมีอยู่วันนึงครูเอ็ม
ปวดท้อง
คู๋หน้าเป็นอย่างนี้กูเองท้องใหญ่
อันนี้กูเอ๋นะคะแล้วก็ท้องผู้ใหญ่คุย
ไม่ใช่มีเด็กนะคะ
ท้องตั้งครรภ์
ไม่ใช่อันนี้คุณเอ๋ไม่ใช่พุงคู๋มีเนื้อ
งอก
โอ๊ยหรอคะที่นี่มีอะที่หมดลูกอ่ะค่ะอ๋อกู
เอไม่สบาย
ที่มดลูกตรงนี้อ่ะค่ะตรงเนี้ยมันมีมัน
ข้างหลังข้างหลังมันมีมันมีเนื้องอก
งั้นเอ๋
3 ก้อน
ก้อนใหญ่มากเลยกูเอ๋
[เพลง]
โอ๊ยเจ็บ
เก็บ
น้องก็อายุสิบประมาณประมาณ 10 ขวบมั้งค่ะ
อีกถึง 11 ขวบแบบอ่าโอเคไม่แน่ใจก็มานะ
ประมาณ 10
น้องก็ดูคู๋น้องป้าเก๋ป้าเก๋เจ็บไหมคะ
ป้าเก๋ก็อ่อเจ็บค่ะ
เก๋อะข้างในมีฟุตบอลใช่ไหมคะ
ฟุตบอลเลยลูกใหญ่มากได้พระเอกใช่ค่ะข้าง
ในมีฟุตบอล
ไปเองไม่มีน้องเหรอคะป้าเอ๋มีฟุตบอลออก
ใช่ฟุตบอลฟุตบอลออกมีผู้เห็นหลอกเด็กว่า
กูเองไม่ได้หรอกคุณแม่หรอกอ่ะ
ดูหน้าน้องเนี่ยน้องอ่าเนาะน้องมะลิพี่
น้องมะลิมะลิน้องมะลิเนี่ยอ่ะชอบกินกิน
เสร็จแล้วก็นอนหนอ
เมื่อตอนไม่เป็นกินและวิ่งแต่ตอนเนี้ยกิน
แล้วคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ก็เลยบอกว่ามะลิถ้ามะลิกินแล้วก็
นอน
มานี่จะมีลูกบอลในท้อง
ป้าเอ๋อ๋อ
คุณแม่บอกป่ะไม่บอกว่าป้าเอ๋นี่มีเนื้อ
งอกจะบอกมีฟุตบอล
อังกฤษฟุตบอลใช่มั้ยตายก่อนฟุตบอลคุณแม่
ซ้อมลุงฟุตบอล
ก็บอกแล้ว
มันจะมีฟุตบอลมะลิก็เลยจริงไม่จริงมาลีก็
ถามป้าอาเจ๊ท่านกินแล้วนอนมีฟุตบอลในท้อง
จริงไหมคะฮ่าๆๆมาเป็นครูต้อมกูต้องจะตอบ
อะไร
จริงค่ะ
[เพลง]
พระเอกก็มองคุณแม่คุณแม่
แม่ก็
ไม่คุยบอกว่าจริงไว้ก่อนจริงไม่จริงเออ
เอ้ยอีกคิดคลิปๆๆเออเขาบอกว่ามีฟุตบอล
ก็ไม่ใช่ฟุตบอลเนี่ยคู๋คู่เอกช่องหุ้นลง
อ๋อ
คู่เอกกูเอกก็เลยบอกว่าอ่า
มันไม่ใช่ฟุตบอลโลก
แต่ว่าชอบกินแล้วนอนหนูจะท้องใหญ่ๆแล้ว 1
เดี๋ยวจะปวดท้องเหมือนพระเอก
[เพลง]
ถ้ากินแล้วนะห้ามนอนต้องเดินหรือนั่งเดิน
ๆให้เสร็จก่อนไม่นอนแล้วก็อันนี้ไม่กินอะ
นี้ไม่กินอันนี้ไม่กิน
อันนี้กินแล้วไม่ดีกินอันนี้ยิ่งแอปเปิ้ล
โอเค
แครอท OK  ka
ไก่น่ะรักไก่อันนี้เป็น
อีกไก่น่ะ
ไม่ดี
ห้ามกินขาก็บอกเด็กแล้วก็ฟังแต่ว่าถ้ากิน
แล้วก็นอนท้องก็จะใหญ่แล้วก็ใหญ่
ปวดท้องปวดท้องหมอ
[เพลง]
คะเด็กๆนะตู้วิ่งกับแม่อยู่ตรงนี้แม่อยู่
แม่แม่ไม่เอ๋บอกไม่ใช่ลูกบอล
แต่ท่านกินแล้วนอนจะปวดท้อง
ขอ
6 งั้นหนูหนูไม่กินแม่แม่ก็เข้าใจว่ากู
เอ๋เป็นคนพูดตรงๆ
แม่ก็หัวเราะแล้วก็บอกก็มันเหมือนลูกบอล
หือแต่ว่าเด็กเค้าก็ไม่กินแล้วก็นอนอีกนะ
เขากลุ่มดีมากเลยค่ะกลัวปวดท้องนะกลัวปวด
ท้องเพราะว่าไปเอกก็ให้ดูนี่ไงลูกของลูก
สีมีมีแฮะ
โอ้โห้โย้โห้ถ้าครูต้อมเป็นเด็กกูต้องก็
กลัวค่ะเพราะว่ามองเห็นแผลของผู้เองใช่
กูเองมากกว่าฟุตบอลอีกนะคะค่ะลูกบอลเด็กๆ
ชอบไงใช่ค่ะมีฟุตบอลก็ดีนะคะก่อนก็ดีก็มี
ฟุตบอลแล้วก็เตะฟุตบอล
เด็กๆก็จะชอบราคาการที่เป็นเรื่องเรื่อง
ที่เราจะจะอธิบายให้เด็กครูเอ๋ชอบพูดแบบ
นี้นะคะแต่บางทีคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไทยก็เอาพูด
สั้นๆง่ายๆแต่ก็คิดดีดีให้เด็กอะนอนหรือ
ให้เด็กไม่นอนจะคืนฮะกินกินอาหารเสร็จนอน
ก็ไม่ดีฉันและไงใช้กะว่าถ้าเด็กๆนอนแบบ 4
เที่ยงคืนเนี้ยไอ้ 11:00 นก่อน 11:00 น
11:00 นดีไหมคะไม่ดีค่ะดูไม่ดีงั้นก็จะ
มีเทคนิคให้เด็กเข้าไปนอนนะคะแบบคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ก็โอเคแบบครูต้องก็โอเคแต่แบบครู
เอ๋เนี่ยเด็กทุกคนรีบไปนอน
หรือริบหยุดหน่อย
ค่ะทุกคนบอกกูเอง
เหรอชอบพูดตรงๆ
กูต้องแบบไหนดีคะตรงหรือว่าฟุตบอล
โรงก็ดีค่ะฟุตบอลที่บีค่ะเพราะว่าเด็ก
เล็กๆบางทียังคิดไม่ได้ก็เป็นฟุตบอลไปก็
ได้ค่ะน้อ
เฮ้ยยังมีเวลาไม่มีเวลาอีกนิดหน่อยนะคะ
อ่ามีอันนี้ตัวเองไม่รู้วันนี้อันนี้รูป
อะไร
ตาค่ะตาเจ๊ดีหรือเปล่าคะการเจ็บตาสีอะไร
คะตาสีแดงค่ะกูเอ๋ตาแดงกูต้องเลี้ยง
เวลาคุณต้องเด็กๆอ่ะแล้วเห็นคนตาแดงน่ะ
ต้องทำยังไงคะเวลาเห็นคนที่เป็นตาสีแดง
นี้นะคะ
ต้องแลบลิ้นให้เขาค่ะ
อ้าวหรอแร็พลืมเล่นกับอะไรต่อแลบลิ้น
เสร็จแล้วก็วิ่งหนีไปเลยค่ะเอาล่ะค่ะ
คือ
ครูเอกก็ได้ยินนะเวลากูอ่ะเด็กๆแม่เหมือน
กันพ่อไม่บอกแต่แม่บอกแม่บอกว่าเห็นคนตา
แดงห้ามไปใกล้ให้แลบลิ้นห้องแล้วก็หนีใช่
ค่ะ
เพราะว่าถ้าเราอยู่ใกล้ตาจะสีแดงเหมือน
กันเหมือนเขาให้ค่ะหมอเขาเขาบอกให้แลบ
ลิ้น
แวะ
ไปเลย
เพราะพ่อแม่เขาไม่อยากให้เราเป็นตาแดงเลย
ค่ะอยู่ใกล้ๆกันติดกันเดี๋ยวจะมีเชื้อโรค
ไม่ได้เราก็อยู่ใกล้ๆได้ทำไมต้องแลบลิ้น
เอกคิดนะถ้าเราไม่ใกล้เพื่อนบอกมากๆๆถ้า
เราและบินแม่เพื่อนจะโกรธแล้วเพื่อนกันไป
เลยไปเลยไม่ต้องมาใกล้เลยไม่ต้องมาเล่น
เลยงั้นเด็กสองคนก็จะห่างกันใช่ไหมคะอ่ะ
ตาแดงนี้เป็นไวรัสเนาะให้ค่ะเป็นไวรัส
เป็นชื่อไวรัสเข้าตาทำให้แบบรูปคันขยี้
ขยี้ขยี้แบบนี้ค่ะขอแล้วถ้าเราและบินแก้
เพื่อนก็กรงโกรธวันนี้
ก็ต้องตนเรือนก็ไม่มาใต้ประกาศแดงหาย
เสร็จก็ขอโทษค่ะเล่นกันจ้า
แต่เราก็ต้องดูว่าเพื่อนหายตาแดงหรือยัง
นะคะก็หาเพื่อนตาไม่แดงก็ยิ้มนะเพื่อนยัง
ตาแดงอยู่ก็
ไม่ได้เพื่อนวิ่งตามแล้วต่อยเพื่อนอาจจะ
ต่อยได้
เก๋ไม่เคยรับลิงค์คุย
แลบลิ้นในใจยังไง
[เพลง]
นี่ก้ๆๆ
เนี่ย
จุดแบบนี้ค่ะเด็กคิดแบบนี้เอาผู้ใหญ่หลอก
เด็กเอาไว้
ราคาอาร์อาร์มีอีกไหมคะ
ๆๆ
บางคนก็บอกกันนี้ค่ะอันนี้เอาอันนี้อัน
นี้งูเหลือมงูเหลือมคุณภา
ไปโดนผู้ใหญ่หลอกอะไรที่เกี่ยวกับงู
เหลือม Mega กูต้องไม่เคยโดนผู้ใหญ่หรอก
เกี่ยวกับงูเหลือมแต่ว่าครูต้องน่ะไปหล่อ
ลูกของครูต้อมเองเอาหลอกว่าอะไร
อันนี้กูต้องคิดขึ้นมาเองนะคะว่าเด็กๆชอบ
กินขนม
นอนแล้วก็กินอ๋ออ๋อนอนไปกินไปนอนไปกินไป
ดูทีวี
มายไม่ใช่กูอีกกูต้องกลัวลูกติดข้อก็นอน
กิน
ขอทราบว่าจะอาหารปิดคอค่ะเดี๋ยวก็ถ่ายใจ
ไม่ออก
แต่คุณต้องไม่ของลูกเหรอท่านอนกินเดี๋ยว
ติดคอเดี๋ยวไม่สบาย
บอกด้วยค่ะแต่ไม่เชื่ออออแล้วถูกต้องเลย
แต่ว่าอะไรคะ 5 นอนกินหลักแรงล่างตายเป็น
งูเหลือม
รู้ลูกหยุดไหมหยุดถ้าลูกโอเคไม่นอนนั่งรถ
ขึ้นกินจากที่นอนกินก็ลุกขึ้นมาอ่ะนั่ง
กินค่าอ๋อดีมากมากได้ผลคอร์สบอกว่าอะไรนะ
ติดคอไม่เชื่อติดคอไม่เชื่อค่ะลุกขึ้นใน
ลุกขึ้นมาลุกขึ้นมานั่งกินไม่ไม่จะนอนกิน
เดี๋ยวเป็นงูเหลืองนะถ้านอนอิ่มจะเป็นงู
เหลืองนะลูกเขาจะไม่เอา
นำ
เรียบร้อยค่ะ
เนาะอะหมดเวลานะคะค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนครับ
พ่อแม่ไทยไม่ได้คิดจะหลอกลูกจริงๆมีเหตุ
ผลถ้าพูดตรงไม่ฟังไม่ฟังเราก็ต้องหลอกเขา
ให้เขากลัวนิดหน่อยสำหรับเขาไปนอนสำหรับ
เขาไม่นอนแล้วก็กินหรือสะอาดเขาไม่กิน
เสร็จแล้วก็นอนนะคะ
เพื่อให้เขาแข็งแรงนะคะไอ้แข็งแรงนะคะถ้า
พูดลงพูดตรงแล้วไม่ฟังก็ต้องมีเทคนิคหลอก
นิดหน่อยรออีกนิดหน่อยถ้า
หากอูเอน่ะกูอ่ะจะพูดตรงแล้วเด็กทำพ่อ
เพราะว่าฟังแล้วโกรธ
แต่พ่อแม่และครูต้องก็คิดว่าถ้าลูกโตขึ้น
นะคะเขาจะเข้าใจได้
อ่า
ขึ้นนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเลยนะดูผู้
กำกับคุยไปก่อนนะคะแล้วพบกันใหม่คลิปหน้า
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋บ๊ายบายค่ะ
คุณต้องบ๊ายบายน